the new york post is also reporting
moments ago that fbi agents scoured
melania trump's wardrobe
and spent several hours combing through
trump's private office joining joining
us now this one we're trump acting a.g
matt whitaker and harmony dylan
chairwoman of the republican national
lawyers association matt aside from uh
what we just heard you think there are a
couple of other objectionable uh things
that happened with this raid tell us
yeah well first of all i think it's not
the least
disruptive way that they could have
obtained this information obviously a
subpoena or continued negotiation i
think if i was in that chair as attorney
general i would have tried to find every
way to continue to have them at the
table negotiate and find a way to get
this so we didn't have to execute a
search warrant i just think it's
draconian uh to have a former president
united states subpoenaed like this now
harmy the the wardrobe they're rummaging
around in melania's wardrobe i don't
know if they were trying on the clothes
i don't know looking in the pockets i
don't know what's going on but this is
just the keystone cops they are
obviously
grasping at straws after liz cheney gave
everybody their marching orders last
week the week before and eric holder
all those other people down the line
laura this is just embarrassing i mean
we are taught as kids to respect the
police and then as lawyers to respect uh
the operation of our justice system and
then you see this type of
just bizarre behavior to matt's point
not only is it the last resort if you're
the president to have a search warrant
executed against you it should be the
last resort for any citizen particularly
one whose lawyers are actively engaging
with the law enforcement agency like
president trump's lawyers were what
should have been done here is seeking a
subpoena and then having the president
hash it out and the president's lawyers
hash it out with the doj about that but
instead they've chosen this really
disgusting display and i think it's
going to have a long lasting impact on
the credibility of the institution matt
tell us about uh reinhardt the
magistrate in this case yeah well
overseeing a lot's come out i mean first
of all he's a obama donor uh he
represented uh epstein and others uh in
in that situation in florida and some
believe that he had a bright legal
future uh ultimately you know in and had
promoted him to as high as the supreme
court possibly who is this is a
scuttlebutt among
yeah you know they're they qualify these
lists and they don't but they don't
publish them like president trump did
but you know the the people that i've
talked to that that know he was on a
path possibly in an earlier time to you
know to either be an article three judge
or ultimately serve at a much higher
level than he finds himself today that's
kind of a that's kind of a
great gimme for the democrats and for
anyone who wants to get trump you get
this guy
manager i was wondering why they got the
the search warrant in west palm beach of
all places and i don't know if they were
magistrate shopping if they decided this
that's where they're going to do the
case or or this all stinks to high
heaven it does every choice they made
was to advantage themselves in this
we found out in in matt we found out
tonight in the washington post that
they had as they had met with the
investigators back in june
and they had been told to put a lock on
their storage room
right and so they put a lock on the
storage room they locked up the boxes
and then they broke through the lock
you know when they came for the for the
search warrant
and so like
they get enough safe i guess they found
nothing in the safe i don't think the
safe was a new safe hadn't been used
they break the safe cracker i mean this
is just like inspector clouseau stuff
but spectra clue sounds a lot better our
mate
well i don't think it's inspector clue
stuff clue so stuff actually laura i
think it is made for television stuff
and so how do you have the drama that
you need for continue january 6 hearings
without these types of dramatic
incidents like that and you know to to
to
to the point of this magistrate judge
laura there's a lot that we found out
including
that he um he recused himself from the
trump versus clinton lawsuit very
recently you know in the summer of this
year and then
and and also we have found out that he
has these very negative facebook posts
about president trump in 2017 that's
come out this evening as well and so
he recused himself from one lawsuit but
then he's able to rule on this one after
making negative remarks about president
trump in writing back in 2017. so
there's a lot that stinks about the
situation and this particular judge
being on the case now and matt
christopher wray i think it was last
week's made a big point of saying that
folks our folks at the fbi need to avoid
the appearance of bias
or the lack of objectivity in what we do
that was christopher wray last week
how's that working out it's not it's not
working out at all in fact they have
whistleblowers coming to members of
congress and complaining about the
political bias of the fbi well that we
need to hear from more whistleblowers i
mean
we need patriots who are inside these
agencies to explain to the american
people how the will
of of the of the president in some cases
but also how the lack of objectivity is
is just par for the course yeah and how
the law is supposed to be enforced as
well uh without favor
or
uh fear yeah well it's supposed to be a
blind lady justice now the lady that
just has like five eyes all right our
meet matt great to see you both hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else